all right first we got Nathan Gunther
this is Nathan big Gunnar coming
straight out the boot bad there's
Louisiana got a debate club for y'all
who's the better serial killer Jason
Voorhees or Freddy Krueger if you're
asking me I'm going Freddy all the way
because I mean he there's not a time
that he can't get you you always have to
sleep so uh plus Jason scared of water I
mean all I have to do is [ __ ] jump
into a river
I think I'm strong swimmers so I'm gonna
Freddy Kreuger all the way let me know
what you guys think gang gang buzzbuzz
buzzbuzz young man go tiger so
definitely Freddy Krueger I set up a
Freddy Krueger Nightmare Before Elm
Street poster yeah that doesn't mean
here doesn't mean that I grew up a huge
fan so I'm definitely did a defend
Freddy Krueger
yeah you get that ball skin he looked
like you some ball sacks covered skin
here the shitty skin yeah but you get a
fine thing you may not asleep son you
could not sleep Jason doesn't run only
walks right well he's fast lazy I'm not
I'm not gonna say any stereotypes you
shouldn't swim yeah okay okay Jason you
dress alike first of all onesie shitty
weird accouterments all the time axe
hockey mask you know I could easily see
you wearing some of that junk I've seen
you wear a Freddy Krueger sweatshirt
before it was alright well I'm saying
this who is definitely I would go Jason
Voorhees dude because first of all the
guy um could he played goalie played
college goalie first of all people even
know that about one ball so you gotta
say right there he's an athlete dude in
some of his early work he would put
people in he would pick people up in a
sleeping bag and beat him against a tree
bro
stronger I'll give you that he was
strong he was strong i Dre rather run
from Frederick in my dreams then [ __ ]
be laying in a sleeping bag and just
know it any minutes a man could close it
up and [ __ ] used me to tenderize an
elm dude here's the thing Jason's just a
regular dude who's pissed off at the
world
Freddie's like a straight-up monsters
CID your dreams lease no he's everywhere
bro he's not if you're awake een Neumann
[ __ ] no he pops up when you're wake to
well what is that that's cheating dude
how you gonna go to sleep huh how you
ever gonna sleep you could do money
Never Sleeps bro you know what I'm
saying grind bro you know what I'm sayin
stay awake dude you know drive around
the fires by your house disel hashtag
inspo yeah keep it goin bro what I'm
saying is though jason voorhees you
could throw an axe from 200 yards and
hit somebody hit a receiver dude hit
Mike Evans or [ __ ] hit some [ __ ]
running from in the woods here's the
thing okay I just jump in the waters
dumbass can't swim
yeah but an axe can swim you know link
went dude what about that what's had a
fast shark that's a [ __ ] axe boy
you're dead alright I'm Freddie all day
Jays fans say 54% Jason boom you free
don't touch me - keep touching we don't
touch me move your sweatshirt up don't
touch me with all the burns on your
hands from the fire you had to drive
through
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]